(heroic music)
I'm Nadia Drake
with National Geographic.
Today, we're at NASA's
Jet Propulsion Laboratory
with Chris Evans,
who plays Buzz Lightyear
in the new Disney and
Pixar movie Lightyear.
Hanging out
with the intrepid
freshly returned from orbit,
astronaut Tom Marshburn.
I have been completely
fascinated
with space travel, all things
NASA since I was a kid.
So the fact that my
new film, Lightyear,
has let me speak
to actual astronauts
is a real dream come true.
Let's find out what life in space
(heoric music fades out)
is really like.
- [Buzz] Here we go.
(pushes lever forward)
(spaceship takes off)
- [Mission Control] We have lift off.
(curious music)
And of course, Tom
has actually
been to space.
What's it like to look
up into space?
You really fall in love
with the Earth again.
Every continent
has its incredibly beautiful sights.
Do the stars look different?
The stars look gorgeous,
but they don't twinkle
because there's no atmosphere.
During the day,
it's just black.
And that is, to me,
the most riveting thing.
(ship flies through atmosphere)
- [Izzy] I can see stars.
- [Izzy] That is space!
- [Buzz] What is happening right now?
- [Darby] She's afraid of space.
- [Buzz] What?
- [SOX] She should be, it's horrible!
What was harder than you expected
about being in orbit?
It's really hard to move
around with control.
It's hard to stop.
Somebody's got to grab you and
plant you somewhere
and get your feet somewhere.
It amazes me we can get
science done up there
with everything
floating around all the time.
In our film,
Lightyear, Buzz has a robot companion,
SOX, this little cat.
- [SOX] Hello, Buzz.
(Buzz yells)
I am SOX,
your personal companion robot.
How do you cope with being so alone?
We got each other, but we also have
all the mission controls.
And there are some floating
- [Tom] A.I. robots up there.
- [Nadia] Hmm.
Like taking pictures where we need them,
- [Chris] Wow.
- [Tom] put a light, where we need it.
So I've heard that some astronauts
get space sickness.
- [I.V.A.N] Please record your last words.
(answering machine beep)
Do not vomit inside the vehicle.
(digital tape rewinds)
(recording repeating back)
- [Buzz] Do not vomit inside the vehicle.
About three out of five
get some form of nausea.
There's no up, down, left or right.
So your body feels like it's spinning.
Getting used to
that is kind of tough.
And also, your stomach's floating.
Everything
on the inside is floating.
(epic trailer hit)
(pushes button and lever)
(ship jumps to hyperspeed)
(hyperspeed noises)
- [Mission Control] JPL, this is Mission Control, Houston.
-[Chris] Wow.
This is Tom, Chris and Nadia.
We hear you loud and clear, Tom.
Great to hear your voice.
Just seems like yesterday
that you were up here with us.
So, I can only imagine,
what's some of the hardest parts
of training?
We trained in a giant pool
called the Neutral Buoyancy Laboratory.
It enables us to understand
how to move outside.
Years of training goes
into preparing for the actual flight
itself.
(elevator doors open)
A year of work
for a four minute flight.
- [Buzz] Isn't that something?
- [Díaz] Huh.
In our film, Buzz
has to utilize
lightspeed
to accomplish his missions.
How fast were you guys moving
on the journey up there
and how fast you guys moving
now on ISS?
You know, we essentially start at a relative
speed of zero on the ground.
And then with eight
and a half minutes,
we're traveling 17,500 miles per hour.
And that's what we're doing right now,
five miles per second.
- [Kjell] And the other incredible thing
(Chris reacts astonished)
is that when it's time to come
home, we've got to
shed that speed to get home safely.
- [Nadia] I'm curious about
the food on board.
How many Michelin stars
would you give the chefs?
- [Kjell] Our space food lab
does an amazing job, so half of
that food is rehydrated,
we add water to it.
And then the other half is prepared
and then sealed
in these kind of metallic envelopes.
And then we put those
on, essentially a hot plate.
(meal squeals, shakes, and poofs)
(microwave bell dings)
(food slides out and sizzles)
I really miss you guys.
- [Tom] Y'all stay safe,
can't wait to see you.
- [Chris] This was fantastic,
easily the best part of press
I've ever done and probably
one of my favorite
conversations of my life.
Roger that.
- [Nadia] Thanks for joining us here at JPL,
and I hope you enjoyed
hanging out with Tom and Chris
and our friends aboard
the International Space Station.
Disney and Pixar's Lightyear.
Rated PG.
Now playing only in theaters.